INTRO:
For decades,
large companies have been trying to dominate the
online video calling and messaging market. We’ve
seen everything from WebEx, MSN messenger,
and Skype to Google Hangouts and Zoom,
but it seems like people’s favorite doesn’t
come from any of these large companies. Rather,
their top choice is often Discord. This is quite
ironic given that projects like Google and Skype
have billions of dollars behind them and thousands
of employees. After all, Microsoft literally spent
$8.5 billion just to acquire Skype. So, clearly,
they take this sector quite seriously. Yet,
they’re getting crushed by a relatively
small startup that was founded by a gamer.
Skype does technically have more active users
currently clocking in at 300 million while Discord
only has about half of that at 150 million. But
when you consider that Skype was launched in 2003
and that Discord wasn’t launched till 2015, it
becomes clear who’s really winning the user race.
Not to mention, a lot of Skype’s user base
comes from companies forcing their employees
to use Skype while virtually everyone who
uses Discord chooses it out of free will.
So, here’s how a gamer showed up big tech in one
of the most saturated industries in the world.
JASON CITRON:
Taking a look back, the story of Discord dates
back to a man named Jason Citron who was born on
September 21, 1984 in Florida. Jason’s interest
in technology and especially gaming started very
early on in his life thanks to his father and
childhood friends. Apparently, Jason’s father
was a massive fan of technology himself and he was
always tinkering with personal computers in his
free time. At the time, personal computers weren’t
actually all that useful to ordinary people
given that their capabilities were extremely
limited and Windows 3.1 hadn’t even come out yet.
Nonetheless, being a businessman, Jason’s father
could see that PCs were gonna become huge hence
the constant tinkering with PCs. While Jason’s
father’s curiosity no doubt rubbed off on Jason,
Jason says that a lot of his passion for tech
comes from gaming and it was actually a childhood
friend that introduced him to games. Apparently,
one of his childhood friends owned an NES and
Jason had the chance to play Super Mario Bros
on it. Jason describes this experience as
quote “the most amazing thing I’d ever
seen in my entire life.” As he grew older,
his love for gaming evolved from being a player to
being a developer. Jason took his first computer
science class in middle school and became friends
with another coding enthusiast within the class.
Soon after, Jason hosted a sleepover for his 13th
birthday, and once everyone else went to sleep,
Jason and his comp sci friend spent the night
trying to code a role playing game using QBASIC.
Given that this was their first try, the
game probably wasn’t that great; however,
Jason says that this experience made it clear to
him that his career had to be related to gaming.
Moving forward, through the rest of his teenage
years, Jason continued to be an avid gamer.
Some of his favorite games include Super
Metroid, Chrono Trigger, Earthbound,
Uniracers, Street Fighter, Mortal Kombat, and most
importantly Final Fantasy VI. Aside from gaming,
Jason started to use his knowledge of computers
to start earning income as a teenager.
Jason says that he quickly realized that most
people were relatively clueless about computers
which gave him an opportunity to help them
fix computer problems and earn some money.
Jason’s father was especially supportive of
this endeavor and would regularly drive him
all around the neighborhood, so that he
could make this side hustle a reality.
As Jason slowly built up a reputation as being a
computer prodigy, people started to ask him to do
bigger tasks such as writing code for them. In
fact, this side hustle grew so big that Jason's
parents helped him set up a bank account and Jason
started receiving wire transfers from customers.
If your customers are using wire transfers to
pay you, you were clearly making big money.
Despite this, Jason didn’t instantly delve
into starting a full on development company.
He says that he was intimidated of hiring people,
so he preferred to keep his side hustle a solo
venture. But, with Jason’s ambitions, it was just
a matter of time until his projects outgrew him.
MOBILE DEVELOPER:
Moving into college, Jason attended Full
Sail University in Florida presumably to
major in computer science. Given that Jason had
been coding for several years at this point,
college wasn’t that difficult for him and he
would end up graduating early. After graduation,
Jason moved to San Rafael, California and picked
up a job as a console game developer. Initially,
he got himself his own place and lived alone, but
he says that this got boring pretty quickly. So,
he moved into a college house and became
roommates with 9 UC Berkeley students.
While this may seem suboptimal at first glance,
this actually turned out to be extremely valuable.
You see, about 6 months after moving into
the house, a man named Rohan Relan moved in.
Like Jason, Rohan was a software enthusiast
and his uncle and he were actually planning
on launching an incubator called YouWeb that was
supposed to help mobile games get off the ground.
As you would guess, Jason was extremely intrigued
by this idea, and Rohan would eventually invite
Jason to join the incubator. At the incubator,
Jason would meet another developer named Danielle
Cassley and together, they would develop their
first major mobile game called Aurora Feint.
The game combined two of Jason's favorite
genres which were role playing games and
puzzle games. So, Jason was basically living
his dream being able to work on developing a
game that really interested him as a career. All
of this took place in late 2007 and early 2008,
so Apple had just released the iPhone and
the app store wasn’t even a thing yet.
Jason and Danielle weren’t exactly developing the
game specifically for the iPhone, but once the
app store was launched, it was clear to them
that they had to address the iPhone market.
This was actually perfect timing because it
allowed Aurora Feint to be one of the first
games on the app store. And given that most of the
original apps on the app store weren’t that great,
Aurora Feint was quickly able to build up a solid
user base of over 1 million users. Despite this,
the game wasn’t very profitable given that
there was no recurring revenue from customers.
Apple didn’t even support in-app purchases at the
time, so Jason and Danielle only earned money on
the upfront cost of the game which was $1. At one
point, Jason only had two months worth of funding
left, and he remembers calling his parents
and telling them that he might need to move
in with them. But, luckily for Jason, that’s
when he would come up with his best idea yet.
OPENFEINT:
Jason’s breakthrough moment came when he was
having a conversation with Rohan’s uncle, Peter,
about where to take Aurora Feint. During this
conversation, Jason said that it was weird that
XBox live wasn’t available on iPhone. Given
how fast the mobile gaming market was growing,
you would think that either Microsoft or Apple
would’ve released something similar to XBox live,
but this wasn’t the case. And this is when Rohan’s
uncle realized that Aurora Feint already had
aspects of XBox live within it. So, it wouldn’t
be that difficult to create their own version of
XBox live called OpenFeint. Jason didn’t have any
money left though, so he pitched this idea to a
few investors who agreed to fund the app if he
could prove that game developers would support
the venture. Later that week, Jason posted the
idea of OpenFeint on TechCrunch which resulted
in hundreds of game developers signing up and
pleading their support. And with that Jason was
funded and he would code like crazy over the
next several weeks. And on February 17, 2009,
Jason would launch OpenFeint. Given that there no
native alternative and the overwhelming support
from game developers, OpenFeint quickly caught on
amongst mobile gamers. OpenFeint’s user base grew
into the tens of millions which allowed Jason
to complete funding rounds that each raised
millions. It looked like things couldn’t get any
better, and that’s exactly when Apple launched
Game Center. Jason said that he felt like the
air was being sucked out of his lungs as he
realized that he was now competing against Apple.
Despite Jason’s fears, Game Center actually ended
up being a massive propellant for OpenFeint. You
see, Jason integrated OpenFeint into Game Center
and integrated Game Center into OpenFeint.
So, OpenFeint users could enjoy the benefits
of OpenFeint while new Game Center users could
naturally discover OpenFeint. It was a win-win
scenario, and at the peak of OpenFeint’s success,
they boasted 120 million users and supported 7000
games. Given this popularity, I don’t think you’d
be too surprised to hear that GREE would go on to
buy OpenFeint for $104 million. It’s not clear
what percentage of OpenFeint Jason owned before
the acquisition, but I think it’s safe to assume
that this sale made Jason a multi millionaire at
the very least if not a deca millionaire. While
Jason has a pretty nice ending, the same cannot
be said about OpenFeint. Around the same time,
a coalition of gamers would sue OpenFeint for
violating their privacy, and a little over a year
later, GREE would announce that they’re shutting
down OpenFeint due to overwhelming backlash.
And that was the bitter end of OpenFeint.
DISCORD:
While losing
OpenFeint was likely a massive blow for
Jason, he was pretty well off financially.
So he had the luxury of taking some time off
and focusing on something else. Initially, Jason
actually turned to creating another gaming company
called Hammer & Chisel in 2012. This company would
release a mobile game called Fates Forever,
but this never really garnered much attention.
Disappointed by the launch, Jason often spent
a lot of his time playing games like Final
Fantasy XIV and League of Legends. One of
the first things that stuck out to him as he
played these games was that their in game voice
communication services were absolute garbage.
Soon after, Jason set out to develop a user
friendly voice communication service that had
minimal impact on game performance, and that’s
how Discord was founded. Over the next year
Jason worked with YouWeb to develop Discord, and
given that he’d been a gamer for his entire life,
he knew exactly what gamers wanted. Jason would go
on to launch Discord in May of 2015, and he says
that he didn’t market it to any specific audience.
But naturally, one of the first communities
that started embracing the platform were gaming
subreddits. This quickly made it popular amongst
Twitch streamers and eventually eSports and LAN
tournament gamers. One of the first companies
that saw the potential of Discord was Time Warner
Cable who invested into the company in late 2016.
Two years later, Microsoft would also embrace the
company by bringing Discord support to Xbox live
users. Microsoft would actually eventually try
to buy Discord for $12 billion, but Jason would
turn down this offer in April of 2021. And given
that Discord has since successfully completed a
funding round at a $15 billion valuation, it looks
like turning down the acquisition deal was the
right decision. But, it’s not all sunshines and
rainbows ahead for Discord. Given that Discord
doesn’t directly charge any of its users, they’re
revenue per user is likely not that great. And
considering how they’re constantly completing new
funding rounds, it’s likely that Discord is losing
money. This is fine for a startup, but you can
only keep up a money losing company for so long.
So, Discord needs to focus on monetization
and profitability ASAP, but I think Jason is
well aware of that, and that’s exactly what he’s
trying to do. So, over the next couple of years,
it’s likely that Discord only grows even bigger
and potentially even becomes the world’s largest
voice communication platform, but we’ll just have
to wait and see. What’s your favorite aspect about
Discord? Comment that down below. Also, drop
a like if you think that Discord blows out the
competition. And of course consider checking out
our international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.